Okay.
Schönen guten Abend, Oosan ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Asstana-Statich
und möchte gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ich werde Ihnen erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann zu Ihrem Beschein überlegen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache mir, ich habe mal guckt nach mir
und hilft mir, ja.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Namen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vornamen ist ziemlich lang.
Magdalena, M-A-G-G-A-L-E-N-A.
Magdalena, eigentlich zwei Namen hinter anderem.
Und Schmidt, S-C-H-M-I-W-T.
D-T oder Doppel-T?
T-T am Ende, zwei T.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Ra-Schmidt oder?
Ja, Frau.
Wie heißen Sie?
56.
Okay.
Wann gehen Sie geworden?
Am 11.06.68.
Können Sie bitte Ihnen sagen, wie viel wegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege so 79 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Okay.
Wo wohnen Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich wohne in der Obersteinwohnung, natürlich, ja, klar.
Edelstein, Stahl.
Okay.
Wie heißt Ihre Hausärztin oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Dr. Huber.
Huber?
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufrausch.
Reiseverkehr?
Kaufrausch.
Ich arbeite im Reisebüro.
Zum Glück geht es wieder los.
Wenn Sie da viel verreist.
Ja, da habe ich viel zu tun.
Darf ich Sie fragen, ob Sie verheiratet sind?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon ziemlich groß.
Ich habe sogar schon 3 Enkelkinder.
3 Erwachsenen.
Ja, so eine Tochter ist noch zu Hause,
aber ein Sohn und eine Tochter sind aus dem Haus schon.
2 Tochter, 1 Sohn.
Super.
Danke schön.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für Stiches für uns?
Ich mache mir Sorgen um meinen rechten Arm.
Der tut mir so weh.
Der ist total geschwollen.
Er fühlt sich auch ganz heiß an und ganz rot.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann ihn gar nicht mehr bewegen,
weil er so dick ist.
Das spandt alles richtig, weil das so prall ist.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat langsam angefangen.
Ja, das habe ich gesagt, 2-3 Tagen.
Da hat es ein bisschen weh getan.
Und dann dachte ich, hast du halt gehoben?
Aber es ist jetzt immer mehr geworden.
Es ist immer richtig prall und rot.
Da komme ich doch mal ganz schnell zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen ausstrahlen?
Nein, nein, nur der Arm tut weh.
Anders kann ich nirgendwo hinstrahlen.
Nein, nein, das ist nur der Arm, der weh tut.
Haben Sie enge Gefühle oder Borstkorbschmerzen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nur der Arm, der tut nur weh.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen gibt?
Was der aussieht, aber weiß ich nicht.
Besonders tut der Arm jetzt natürlich,
wenn ich ihn runterhängen lasse, ich halte ihn immer so ein bisschen fest.
Dann tut es nicht so weh.
Also wenn er runterhängen, ist es besonders unangenehm.
Oder natürlich, wenn ich versuche, mit dem Arm irgendwas anzuheben
oder so, ich hole den jetzt halt total, dann geht es.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von einem bis sehen,
vorbei ein sehr leichtes Sehen der starksten Schmerzen ist?
Oh, das ist schon unangenehm und tut schon sehr weh.
Kurz über der Hälfte würde ich vielleicht sagen,
das ist ja 6, also es tut schon sehr weh.
Und gerade wenn ich dagegen komme, das tut also wirklich weh.
6?
Okay, haben Sie noch weiter beschweren?
Nee, aber das reicht mir völlig angesprochen.
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay, ich fasse das noch einmal kurz zusammen,
bitte korrigieren Sie mich, falls ich etwas falsch notiert habe.
Sie habe seit 2 bis 3 Tagen rechten Arm Schmerzen
und total geschwollene, ganz rot und Prellung und keine Bewegung.
Keine Bewegung nicht.
Also es spannt halt, ein Wiederstand, wenn ich versuche, den Arm zu bewegen.
Nur erspannt, okay.
Und Ihre Schmerzskala 6 bis 10, okay.
6 von 10, hm?
Leiden Sie einen chronischen Erklangung, von den ich wissen sollte?
Ja, auf alle Fälle, klar.
Lassen Sie mich überlegen, es ist jetzt schon 14 Jahre her.
Ich war noch sehr jung, da hatte ich eine Brustoperation.
Und damals hat man auch festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Und ja, vor ein paar Jahre später hat man dann auch noch festgestellt,
dass meine Blutfettwerte auch ein bisschen so hoch sind.
Aber ja, sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Wie wurde es behandelt gegen Artilärelechipet, Hypertony und...
Ja, da nehme ich halt Tabletten, hm?
Ich nehme Conco5 und dann nehme ich noch Diovan.
Conco und Diovan.
Diovan, wie ist Dosierung?
Diovan, ich meine, da steht 160 drauf, dann nehme ich morgens eine.
Und Conco5 nehme ich morgens auch eine.
Aber sonst nehme ich eigentlich keine Tabletten.
Sind Sie schon einmal Operatoren, haben Sie gesagt, Brustoperation?
Ja, genau, auf der rechten Seite ja.
Und also seinerzeit ist das total operiert worden.
Und ich habe Bestrahlung bekommen danach.
Bestrahlung.
Und als Kind, ah so, dann war natürlich noch gar nicht so lange her.
Vor einem Jahr habe ich eine neue Hüfte rechts bekommen.
Hüfte operatoren?
Haben Sie letzte Zeit einen Unfall gehabt, oder?
Sie meinen, ob ich mich irgendwo gestoßen habe oder so.
Nein, deswegen wundern mich, warum ich das so weh tut, ja.
Ich habe mich nicht gestoßen und kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass ich mir irgendwo weh getan habe.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie nach Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie fragen.
Leben Ihre Eltern hoch?
Nein, mein Vater ist früh gestorben, meine Mutter, die lebt noch.
Okay.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Woran sind Ihr Vater gestorben?
Woran ist, ja, der ist gestorben.
Der war nicht alt, der hat Mitte 50 ein Herzinfarkt gehabt und war ganz schnell gestorben.
Und also einer meiner Brüder, also einer meiner Geschwister,
ist auch ganz früh gestorben.
Der hatte auch, der war ein bisschen älter als ich.
Da hatte der ein Herzinfarkt vor viel Jahren.
Bruder und Geschwister?
Bitte?
Bruder und Geschwister.
Mein Bruder und meine Schwester, ja, die ist leider auch genauso krank wie ich.
Die hat nämlich auch Brustkrebs gehabt, das hat man vor einem Jahr festgestellt.
Leiden Mutter an Krankungen?
Meine Mutter ist eigentlich, die hatte auch eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Irgendwann und ansonsten weiß ich, dass sie ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat,
aber sonst ist sie erstaunlich fit.
Ihre Vater hat nur Herzinfarkt oder andere chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der sonst noch irgendwas hatte,
aber ich weiß, dass er an einem Herzinfarkt letztlich gestorben ist, ja.
Nur ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Frauenheilkunde.
Wann hatten Sie Ihre erste und letzte Monatsblutung?
Oh, die erste Regel war so 13.
Und ja, die letzte, ja, war so mit 45.
Ich habe also sehr früh bin ich in die letzten Jahre gekommen.
Haben Sie entschluckt, besuchen Sie regelmäßig so Frauenheilkunde?
Ja, natürlich.
Einmal lasse ich nach der Brust natürlich immer gucken
und ansonsten zur Krebsvorsorge gehe ich auch.
Das war zuletzt jetzt ungefähr vor einem Vierteljahr.
Ist in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, war alles in Ordnung, ja.
Weiter geht es mit der vegetativen Amnesie.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber? Nein, also nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich habe aber nicht gemessen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich für mich oder etwas?
Nein, nur der Arm fühlt sich eigentlich heiß an.
Ich selber fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig.
Leider sind nach Schweiß oder Schweißausbruch?
Nein, jetzt nicht mehr.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, normalerweise, aber jetzt die letzten Nächte habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen,
weil ich nicht wusste wohin mit meinem Arm.
Aber normal schlafe ich eigentlich schon ganz gut, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich gut immer.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturlgang und beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, das ist alles, würde ich sagen, sehr normal bei mir.
Haben Sie vermeint, dass Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenau?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich seit langer Zeit ziemlich stabil.
Ich kann mir sagen, ob Sie in Ihrer Berufs- und Privatsch-Leben-Streche Stress oder Angst haben.
Angst oder Stress?
Stressig ist es immer mal, aber ich würde sagen, wir sind froh,
dass es jetzt wieder alles normal läuft, dass diese Einschränkungen aus der Corona-Zeit vorbei sind
und wie gesagt, die Leute verreisen wieder viel.
Wir haben viel zu tun, aber das ist ja gut.
Es ist besser, als wenn wir da rum sitzen und nichts tun.
Wir haben gesagt, Konko und Giovanna angenommen.
Das nehme ich regelmäßig?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie andere regelmäßige Medikamente ein?
Andere Medikamente nehme ich sonst nicht.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen?
Nein, rauchen tu ich nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich würde nicht sagen, ich trinke nie Alkohol, aber gelegentlich trinke ich Alkohol.
Wenn es das zu feiern, wenn man mal ein sehr gutes Essen hat,
wenn man Freunde eingeladen hat oder so, da trinke ich schon ein Glas Wein mit
oder auch mal zwei, aber ich würde sagen, regelmäßig trinke ich sicherlich kein Alkohol.
Diese Frage ist rotunemmäßig.
Bitte nehmen Sie sie nicht, aber haben Sie Kontakt mit Drohren?
Mit Drohren?
Also da habe ich noch nie irgendwie etwas genommen.
Wissen Sie, ob Sie allerlei gegen bestimmte Nahrungsschmitte, Medikamente oder Unvertretlichkeiten haben?
Anergien.
Ja.
Also bisher habe ich immer alles vertragen.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass irgendetwas ist,
dass ich nicht vertragen kann, auch bei Medikamenten.
Ich habe nun schon viel bekommen, wo haben der ganzen Erkrankungen,
aber da habe ich immer alles gut vertragen.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich allererisch bin.
Ist Ihr Impfstatus vollständig?
Sie meinen, ob ich gegen Corona geimpft bin oder wie?
Kinderheit oder Corona?
Corona bin ich viermal geimpft
und ich habe mir jetzt auch dieses Jahr die Grippe im Punkt wiedergeben lassen.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit ins Ausland gereist?
Vor sechs Monaten?
Nein, warte mal.
Ich war mal in den Niederlanden und ich war mal in Österreich, aber nichts Exotisches irgendwie.
Das war es.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder wichtige Informationen für mich?
Ich will natürlich wissen, was mit dem Arm ist,
warum er mit einmal so weh tut und anspielt und was man dagegen tun kann.
Wir sind schon erledigt.
Ich werde die körperliche Untersuchung durchschulen.
Manche müssen dann auch einiges untersuchen.
Wir haben einen Ultraschall.
Dort ist der Arm extremiert.
Und sobald alle Bel funda for leaving, können wir über die Diagnose und die Behandlung schöpfen.
Okay, gut.
Das war es.
Okay, möchte ich jemand noch etwas Zusätzliches wissen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Ihr Axel und Halsbereich Knoten es gibt?
Ob ich gesvollene Lymphknoten habe.
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, habe ich aber auch nicht abgetastet.
Haben Sie Probleme, wie die Brust, die Veränderung oder die Haut, die Probleme?
Die eine Brust ist ja operiert.
Okay, danke.
Danke.
Wurden wegen der Mavacars nur eine Medikamente behandelt?
Nein, operiert und bestrahlt.
Keine Chemotherapie, oder?
Keine Chemotherapie.
Und können Sie die Finger bewegen?
Die Finger?
Ja, die kann ich bewegen.
Und die Rötung und Schwellung.
Ist der begrenzt oder befürchtet?
Noch mal bitte, ist die begrenzt, oder?
Ja, ist es begrenzt im Arm oder befürchtet?
Befürchtet.
Also eine scharfe Begrenzung ist da nicht.
Aber es ist eher, dass es irgendwie anfängt und sich dann wieder zur Hand hin ist es noch nicht so stark.
Haben Sie zusätzlich Atembeschwerden?
Atembeschwerden habe ich nicht.
Und letzte Frage, hat etwas gebissen oder gestochen?
Ja, ich habe auch nicht irgendwie im Garten gearbeitet, oder so, dass ich mich irgendwo verletzt hätte.
Okay, dann danke.
Ja, sehr gut, danke.
Können Sie dich Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Eigentlich ist es dieser Druck und dieses Spannungsgefühl und es brennt auch ein bisschen.
Spannungsgefühl?
Spannungsgefühl, also dieser Druckschmerz eigentlich.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hallo, Sie haben, Sie wurden rechte Brustoperationen, nur rechte Brust oder auch rechte Aksilarregion-Operationen.
Sie haben Lymphknoten, einen Lymphknoten rausgenommen und der war nicht befallen.
Lymphknoten, Entfernung?
Ja, also einer ist entfernt worden, ja.
Okay, danke.
Wann war Ihre letzte Versuchung?
Vor drei Monaten.
Gibt es auffällig?
Da war keine Auffälligkeit mehr.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie als Arztgespräch machen wollen, ja?
Ich brauche fünf Minuten.
Alles gut?
Schönen guten Abend, Frau Beerst.
Ich bin in einem neuen Patientenvorstellungen, haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Frau Materina Schmidt, 56 Jahre alt, 79 kg und 1,68 m groß.
Und Frau Schmidt ist Reiseverkehrs-Kaufrau, und sie ist ein Hayat.
Sie haben drei Erwachsene, Kinder.
Und Frau Schmidt, ich stelle Sie heute wegen Zeit drei Tage bestehende, drückende Schmerzen
in rechten Arm bei uns vor.
Und die Schmerzen und die Berüchte, dass ihre Arm total geschwollene,
oder total schmerzene, der Arm ist geschwollene.
Und ihr Bein sei ganz rot und krellung.
Noch mal, das habe ich überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Noch mal bitte.
Ihre Arm sei ganz rot und krellung.
Nicht krellung.
Eine Krellung wäre ja ein Trauma.
Ich habe gesagt, der ist prall geschwollene.
Also wie Luftballon.
Spannungsgefühl.
Spannungsgefühl hat sie da drin.
Die Frage nach wurde verneint, keine Unfall.
Die Frage nach einem Trauma wurde verneint.
Oder es gab keinen Unfall vorher oder keine Trauma dieser Umfälle.
Und die Schmerzintestät liegt bei sechs von zehn auf einer Skada.
Und die Bekretative der Namnese war unaufwändig bis ins Omni wegen des Schmerzen.
Und die Bekannte für die Erkrankung sei Artilielle Hypertonie.
Die Bekannte war unaufwändig bis ins Omni wegen des Schmerzen.
Und die Bekannte war unaufwändig bis ins Omni wegen des Schmerzen.
Ja, also die Mama-Karsinom.
Mama-Karsinom, die Operation durchgeführt.
Und dann wurde sie Strahlen- oder Radiotherapie.
Bekamen sie eine Radiotherapie oder wurde sie mit einer Strahlentherapie behandelt?
Und sie wurde teb-hüft-tep durchgeführt.
Noch mal bitte.
Operation oder Hüft?
Sie bekam eine Hüft-Tep.
Total endoprotease.
Also wurde sie versorgt und wann war das?
Ich habe nicht, natürlich, aber.
Okay, also kürzlich erst vor einem Jahr.
Ja, gut.
Und die Familienanlagen sagst ich,
mein Vater hat die Bekannte an die Hypertonie gestorben.
Der Vater ist an die Hypertonie gestorben?
Beide Mutter, Artilielle Hypertonie.
Und die Bruder, Leide an Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Also ihr Bruder ist an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben?
Ja, eine Hypertom-Fahrstörung.
Und die Schwester, Leide an Brustkrebs.
Also die Mama.
Ebenkalt.
Und die kinoekologische Anamnese,
ihre ménage 13 Jahre.
Mit 13?
Mit 45 Jahre.
Mit 45, ne?
Und sie besuche regelmäßig um Frauenarzt.
Alles in Ordnung.
Und sie rauchen nicht.
Und sie trinken gelegentlich Alkohol.
Manchmal ein Glas Wein.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Und keine Alergie war bekannt.
Also es sind keine Allergien bekannt?
Ja, keine Allergien bekannt.
Und ihre Impfstatus, Volstein ist...
Im Status ist Volstein?
Und ja, das war es.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung? Was fehlt der Patientin?
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angaben
gehe ich vom einem Verdacht auf.
Läme für den auf.
Als differenzial Diagnose kommt...
Dann müssen wir jetzt drei Sachen kommen.
Ja, TvT.
Was ist TvT?
Viele Wut.
Was kann man sagen?
Also tiefe Amwind-Trompose.
Tiefe Wind-Trompose, TvT.
Das war hier jetzt im Angebot gerade.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Praktisch der Vorläufer der Wind-Trompose.
Celulitis.
Ja, viele Wut.
Das könnte sein.
Und das könnte es noch sein, das ist hier gerade gekommen.
So erst würde ich eine körpelsche Untersuchung durchführen.
Warte mal, wir sind noch nicht fertig mit den drei Differenzialdiagnosen.
Also Sie vermuten, die hatten Lymphideen.
Wir haben die tiefe Amwind-Trompose als Differenzialdiagnose.
Wir haben die Windentzündung, also der Vorläufer der Trombose,
die Phlebitis als Differenzialdiagnose.
Und jetzt fehlt uns noch die Dritte.
Da haben wir noch eine wichtige. Die dürfen wir nicht außer Acht lassen.
Ein Kollege hat nachgebracht, ob die ein Insektenstich hatte
oder eine Schnittverletzung an der Hand oder am Arm.
In welche Richtung geht die Frage?
Also es könnte eben auch ein Irresipil sein.
Ja.
So, dagegen spricht eigentlich, dass die Patientin selber sagt,
sie hat keinen Schieber.
Aber der Arm ist heiß, könnte beginnen sein.
Gut, wie ist es vorgehen jetzt?
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Sollte ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen?
Ja, worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Wegen der Inspektion.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich Lesion auf Lesion, Tumor,
Rubo und Asymetrin.
Asymetrin, wichtig, ja, genau, vergleich recht links, genau.
Und dann würde ich Palpation schüren.
Um überwärmung festzustellen, genau.
Ich überprüfe die Vitalparameter, wie laue Stoffstätigung,
die Temperatur, die Pulsverlust, und Artilellambulddruck.
Wo messen Sie den Blutdruck?
Entschuldigung.
Bein oder?
Ne, aber jedenfalls nicht am rechten Arm, sondern am linken Arm.
Beide Arm, beide Arm.
Nein, Gottes will nicht an dem rechten Arm.
Nein, am linken Arm messen Sie den Blutdruck.
Ja, gut, weil der ist ja betroffen.
Gut, okay, wie geht es weiter?
Was machen Sie noch?
Manchmal würde ich den Patientin Bullwit abnehmen.
Der Patientin, wichtig, ne?
Ja, der Patientin Bullwit abnehmen.
Wo nehmen Sie das Blut ab?
Entschuldigung, Parameter.
Wahnsinn, wo nehmen Sie das Blut ab?
Linken Arm.
Ja, gut, ja.
Also, und was bestimmen Sie?
Ja, Entschuldigung, Parameter.
Und das noch?
Ja, und was da speziell?
INR, INR, APTT, und FibriKone, FibriKnodeen.
Ein wichtiger Wert zum Thrombose-Ausschluss.
Die, die mehr.
Die, die mehr, genau, ja, okay, gut.
Ich bin schon zufrieden.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter?
Danach veranstalte ich Sonografie,
duplexe Sonografie,
eine Person.
Was untersuchen Sie genau bei der Sonografie?
Arthäen.
Arthäen und ja, was noch?
Trombose.
Ja, also die Behen, klar, ja.
Und was können Sie unter Umständen noch feststellen?
Durch Blutung.
Ja, genau, ne?
Lymphstoten in der Achsilla und vielleicht auch in der Heißregion,
ne?
Ja.
Ja, dass man guckt, ob da irgendwas auffällig ist, ne?
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, wenn es ein Lymph, also, was spricht denn für das Lymphedämen?
Das reine ausschließlich Lymphedämen, was spricht dafür?
Was spricht dafür?
Die Schwellung.
Ja, dass der amtig ist, das ist ja das klassische beim Lymphedämen.
So, was spricht dagegen?
Was spricht dafür, dass es eher,
was mit einer Entzündung zu tun hat?
Antibiotika, ja.
Bitte?
Antimotherapie.
Ne, ich rede nicht, was Sie therapieren, sondern ich meine,
was spricht für welche Diagnose?
Ja, die Patientin berichtet von einem heißen,
roten, geschwollenen Arm.
Ja.
Und sie berichtet von einer vorausgegangenen
Mama-Katzinom-Operation rechts vor vielen Jahren.
So, das spricht natürlich für das Lymphedämen,
also die Mama-OP, ja.
Aber die Brötung, Schwellung, Überwärmung,
spricht natürlich eher für die Phlebitis
oder für die tiefe Armbandentrompose
oder für das Erisipel.
Da muss man jetzt tatsächlich gucken, was tatsächlich rauskommt.
Aber ich finde es schon mal gut,
dass diese Idee Lymphedämen überhaupt gekommen ist.
Denn das ist ja oftmals so,
dass über das Lymphedämen keiner nachdenkt
nach einer Mama-Katzinom-Operation.
Dabei ist das eine relativ häufige Komplikation.
Gut, ja.
Wir sind also eigentlich schon gleich jetzt in der Diskussion.
Sie haben selber gemerkt,
bei der Anwamnese waren sie sprachlich sehr sicher.
Sie machen zwar grammatikalisch ein paar Fehler,
aber irgendwie nicht so wild.
Bei der, beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch
waren sie deutlich verunsichert.
Da hatten sie erhebliche Formulierungsschwierigkeiten
und haben so ein bisschen nach richtigen Formulierungen gesucht.
Ich kann Ihnen nur empfehlen,
machen Sie sich Standardformulierungen,
die Sie, also eigentlich bin ich kein Freund von Standardisierung.
Ich finde immer individuelle Formulierungen natürlich schön.
Aber Sie können Ihre individuelle Standardformulierung machen.
Dass Sie zum Beispiel sagen,
Familienanalystisch ergab sich für den Vater, für die Mutter.
Das ist einfach ein Unterschied, ob man sagt,
warum muss ich wieder, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau,
wie Sie es formuliert haben.
Aber es ist eben wichtig, er gab sich für den Vater,
er hatte einen Herzinfarkt und ist daran gestorben.
Da kann man eigentlich besser sagen,
Familienanalystisch ergab sich,
dass der Vater frühzeitig an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben ist.
Die Mutter lebt doch,
bei ihr ist eine arteriale Hypertonie bekannt
und sie hatte genau wie unsere Patientin auch
eine Hüftgelängsoperation.
Dann kann man noch über die Geschwister was sagen.
Wobei das ja eigentlich eine dramatische Familiengeschichte ist.
Wenn also die beiden männlichen Verwandten tot sind
und die Schwester eben genauso wie die Patientin selber
Mama-Kazinom hat.
Ja, so.
Und ja,
wir haben also diese,
da gebe es ein paar Standardformulierungen,
die sich vielleicht überlegen
und einfach mal niederschreiben.
Das wäre hilfreich.
Ich habe schon gelernt,
dass in Mainz der Aufbau der Anamnese ein bisschen anders ist
als in den anderen Bundesländern.
Das haben sie genau nach Schema gemacht.
Das will ich auch nicht dran rütteln,
will ich auch gar nichts dran meckern,
was ich tatsächlich gut finde,
dass sie,
gerade bei dieser Patientin natürlich besonders interessant,
die gynäkologische Anamnese mit reinnehmen.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich sehr überrascht war,
als die Frage für mich zum ersten Mal kam im Rahmen meiner X-Jahre.
Jetzt, weil das sehr selten eigentlich vorkommelt.
Aber hier war ich drauf gefasst, da gibt es auch Angaben dazu.
Und ja, was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat,
worauf sie nicht eingegangen sind.
Ach so, es gab noch ein sprachliches Missverständnis.
Die Patientin hat eigentlich ihren Arm, finde ich,
sehr gut geschildert.
Sie hat geschrieben, der Arm tut weh.
Er ist dick, er ist prall geschwollen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie jemals so ein Erisipel
oder ein Thrombosearm gesehen haben.
Der ist ja wirklich dick und geschwollen und schwer.
Er tut weh.
Die Haut glänzt und ist richtig prall wie ein Luftballon.
Das hat nichts mit einer Prellung zu tun,
sondern eben, dass man da so reindrücken kann
und das Fehler hat.
Das war also ein Verständnisfehler,
wo sie die Patientin nicht richtig verstanden haben.
Ich finde auch nicht,
dass sie den Arm jetzt der Oberärztin
so sehr gut geschildert haben.
Das haben sie nicht so gut übertragen,
was die Patientin Ihnen alles erzählt hat.
Sie hat Ihnen ja eigentlich viel erzählt.
Sie hat eben von der Rötung, von der Schwellung,
von der Überwärmung erzählt
und von diesem Prallheitsgefühl.
Und Sie haben eigentlich fast nur über die Schmerzen gesprochen.
Gut, das ist diese Geschichte.
Und ja, womit ich glaube,
eine Patientin ist nicht so gut, was anfangen kann,
wenn Sie als Überschrift sagen,
jetzt habe ich noch Fragen zu Ihrer vegetativen Anamese.
Hä? Was will der mich jetzt fragen?
Also, diese Überschrift brauchen Sie für die Patientin nicht,
sondern da wäre es halt ganz gut,
wenn Sie sagen, fühlen Sie sich fieberig.
Wie ist es mit Ihrem Appetit bestellt?
Gut.
Ja, beim, bei der Diagnose,
wie gesagt, das Lymphidee ist ja eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Aber auch da waren Sie sich nicht so richtig schlüssig,
dass Sie jetzt eigentlich mit der Patientin machen sollen.
Sie haben also gesagt, ja, Klarinspektion,
Seitenvergleich, das ist ja schon mal gut.
Was mir da eigentlich auch noch gefehlt hat,
dass die Angabe kommt, ich gucke nochmal selber,
ob es wirklich keine Eintrittsforte gibt.
Also keine kleine Wunde,
keine Wunde an der Hand,
an den Finger an
oder irgendwo im Oberarm oder Unterarmbereich.
Das kann der Patientin ja entgangen sein.
Also da muss man sicherlich nochmal sehr genau gucken.
Und sicherlich muss man, wenn es um den Ausschuss der TVT geht,
klar, muss man die, die mehrere bestimmen.
Das ist schon klar.
Aber die Sonografie ist natürlich dann die Untersuchung der Wahl.
Der Patientin haben Sie ja auch noch eine Röntgenaufnahme angekündigt.
Das würde man wahrscheinlich heute gar nicht mehr machen.
Weil man eigentlich im Ultraschall in den neuen Geräten so gut gucken kann,
dass man da gar nichts mehr rönten muss.
Und über die TV-Meere haben Sie eigentlich ja den sicheren Trombose-Ausschluss.
Wie wäre denn die Therapie?
Haben Sie da so eine Idee?
Therapie.
Als therapeutische Massnahmen würde ich der Patientin empfehlen.
Stationäre Aufnahmen.
Und zu dem verschreibe ich ja Antibiotikum.
Wenn Sie eine Resipilhexel bräuchte, sind Antibiotikum.
Sonst ist ja nicht.
Ja, und wenn sie eine tiefe Intrombose hat?
Markumal oder?
Ja, Heparin und bzw. die erste Heparin, dann Markumal.
Und was braucht sie noch?
Noch, richtig.
Ja, wir lernen für den.
Nein, wir bleiben mal bei der, bei der Trombose oder bei der Phlebitis
oder beim Irresipäliar.
In jedem Fall, was braucht sie?
Sie braucht eine Kompression.
Ja.
Ja, also zunächst mit Verband.
Nach Abschwellen mit Armstrumpf.
Also auch wenn sie eine Trombose hat.
Muss sie ja, wenigstens ein halbes Jahr, müsste sie in Armstrumpf betragen.
Genau. Physiotherapie natürlich erst nach Abklingen der, der Physiotherapie
wurde hier gerade angeboten.
Erst nach Abklingen der Entzündungszeichen.
Und ja, Hochlagerung ist gut.
Hochlagerung, Kühlung.
Das wären so Sachen, die sicherlich was bringen.
Okay.
Ja, also ich bin ein bisschen in Sorge, weil sie, weil sie sprachlich
im Arztgespräch wirklich sehr, sehr unsicherer waren.
Ich kann ihnen wirklich jetzt nur als Tipp geben, weil das ja nun auch ein bisschen eilt.
Machen sie sich Standardformulierungen für die einzelnen Sachen.
Ja, sie haben ja die verschiedenen Punkte, dass sie dann sagen,
die Patientin kommt wegen, was, was ich, progredienter,
progredienter Armschwellung mit Schmerzen nicht zu viel in den ersten Satzreinstöpfen
und zudem berichtet sie über.
So, da kann man dann noch weitere Symptome aufzählen.
Ja, dann wichtig immer die Frage nach Verletzung,
nach Luftnot, nach Husten, nach, was, was ich wurde verneint.
Ja, da ist man sagt, ich habe danach gefragt, hat sie alles nicht.
Ja, und was ich gut fand, dass sie zu einem relativ frühen Zeitpunkt diese Brust-OP erwähnt haben.
Ja, weil das natürlich in engem Zusammenhang mit dem rechten Arm steht, logischerweise.
Ja, und ich glaube, sie haben erst die Hypertonin und die Hypercholesterin erwähnt,
Hypercholesterin erwähnt, das hätte ich ja an erster Stelle gesetzt.
Ja, aber also, an Vorerkrankungen gibt es hier an,
Zustand nach Brust, nach Mama-Katzinom mit Operationen vor 15 Jahren.
Ja, und die Hüftep war übrigens vor allem ja, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ja, so, dann, ja, und dann können sie natürlich beim Arzt-Aff-Gespräch,
die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Insomnie-Schmerzbedingte.
Ja, das ist schon klar.
Aber wie gesagt, nicht, nicht dem, das raten neu erfinden in jedem Gespräch,
sondern feste Formulierungen machen, damit sie da sicher in der Formulierung sind.
Und machen sie die auch grammatikalisch sicher, dass sie die richtigen Endungen haben.
Ja, da sind sie ein bisschen luschig, sage ich mal.
Ja, das nehmen sie nämlich so genau.
Ich weiß nicht, wie genau das ihre Prüfer nehmen, aber wenn sie die,
wenn sie jetzt Formulierungen sich ausdenken, ja,
dann machen sie es doch so, dass sie die praktisch mal richtig ausformulieren hinschreiben.
Ich biete Ihnen auch sehr gerne an, wenn Sie das möchten,
machen Sie einen schriftlichen Bericht und schicken wir den per E-Mail.
Ja, wenn Sie den als PDF-Datei schicken, kann ich das angucken
und kann Ihnen das Korrigier zurück schicken.
Ja, dass wir grammatikalisch wirklich da keine Fehler drin haben
und dass wir auch vielleicht illegante Formulierungen finden.
Es ist nicht mehr viel Zeit bis zum 14. ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, wir sollten ein bisschen etwas noch dran drehen.
Ja? Okay.
Okay, gut. Ja, das war ein Meinserfall, Frau Schmidt.